les cinq infirmières et le médecin
d'origine palestinienne récemment
naturalisé bulgare sont arrivés ce matin
à sofia peu avant 9 heures une
libération plus rapide que prévu et qui
a pris de court les autorités bulgares
qui hier soir se montraient très
pessimistes
accompagnée de ses filles à sarkozy de
claude guéant le secrétaire général de
l'elysée et de benita ferrero waldner la
commissaire européenne aux affaires
extérieures
les soignants ont été aussitôt gracié
par le président bulgare
l'émotion était vive à leur descente
d'avion récit de leur arrivée samah
soula
combien de fois en huit ans hôtel du
fond de leur cellule imaginé ce moment
celui où elle marcherait fébrilement
vers leurs proches pour pouvoir enfin
les serrer dans leurs bras
les premiers baisers vont aux enfants
ivres de joie
incrédule après tant d'années d'attenté
de rebondissements des fleurs des larmes
pour des retrouvailles après des années
d'absence et de souffrance image de
famille
enfin réunis visiblement éprouvés et
cinq infirmières et le médecin pose pour
la photo de la liberté au pied de
l'appareil français qui les a ramenés de
ligands à l'écart les berges les acteurs
de leur libération sont appelés cécilia
sarkozy claude guéant et la commissaire
européenne
ce sont eux qui ont concrétisé des
négociations qui s'éternisent est le
président bulgare les accueillent
chaleureusement les pousses du président
français semblait exténué
en jouant
la tradition
protocole également pour les infirmières
elle n'en finissent pas de saluer et de
remercier et de pleurer encore
je suis heureuse mais c'est très
difficile pour moi aujourd'hui de dire
ce que je ressens
les infirmières applaudissent
on vient de leur annoncer qu'elles sont
gras c'est par un décret présidentiel
pour elle la prison c'est fini journée
une journée de joie
une journée qui rappelle en tous points
une libération d'otages avec ses zones
d'ombré ces questions sans réponses et
ses négociateurs d'inattendu